Even before she was a fully-fledged doctor, Kate
Barker always had a fascination for the outdoors.
Growing up, being out among nature felt like
she was connected to the wider world, one
part of a larger whole. She intuited from a very
young age that the Earth had a system in place,
full of millions if not billions of parts that
all worked together in the hopes of achieving
perfect balance. Humans, animals, and insects,
right the way down to germs that were so small
they couldn’t be seen unless under a microscope.
And then, of course, there were the plants; trees,
flowers, and all manner of other flora that
provided the world with so much more than
making it look beautiful. And it was, so much
so that a young Kate wanted to devote her life
to helping maintain our beautiful little blue and
green planet, and understanding every part of it.
The ways she did that changed as the years went
on. As a child, it was learning how trees take
in carbon dioxide and water, then use the sun’s
energy to feed themselves and produce oxygen,
through a process known as photosynthesis.
Then, in high school, Kate was writing and
giving presentations on the importance of
protecting the environment and conserving
wildlife, trying to convince her classmates
to see the world in the same way she did.
By the time college rolled around, that protection
took on a seemingly more proactive form,
standing out on picket lines in protest when
the college announced it would be chopping
down its nearby woods to expand the campus.
Eventually, she was made Doctor Kate Barker, and
awarded her PhD in Botany and Plant Science. She
thought that would be when the real work began;
having climbed her way up to achieving
her degree was only the first step,
the next would involve working tirelessly to
keep the world’s greenery alive. After all,
Kate had studied for years, learning about
anything and everything to do with plant life,
their different functions and structures, how
each species had evolved and could be classified,
and how they all formed part
of the planet’s ecosystem.
Unfortunately, even for those with the noblest of
intentions, the harsh, unforgiving laws of reality
can tend to get in the way. In Kate’s case, that
came in the form of being snapped up for a job at
a genetic research company. Sure, on the one hand
she did get to rely on all the information she had
learned on her way to earning her PhD. But, on the
downside, all Kate got to use her knowledge for
was receiving and tending to various plant
samples. Getting asked occasionally to run
tests on those samples was about the
pinnacle of excitement in her job.
Somehow, despite working with plants, Doctor
Barker couldn’t help but feel further away from
nature than she had ever been. That was until an
unusual specimen was brought to her department for
analysis, something unlike anything Kate had
seen in all her years of research and study.
Although she didn’t know it at the time,
this unique plant would bring Doctor Barker
closer to nature in a way she could never have
imagined… because it was a sample of SCP-306.
Of course, at the time, and even after the
plant’s anomalous properties began to take effect,
Kate was completely unaware of this. When it was
first brought to her lab, it seemed like just an
ordinary fungus. No one had been able
to successfully identify it, however,
but if anyone could, Doctor Kate Barker
was perhaps the best-qualified person.
“Where was it found?” she asked the lab
technician as he handed her the sample,
secured in a sealed, airtight container.
“Pretty close to here apparently,” the
lab tech replied. “Louisiana swamps are always
full of mushrooms and stuff like this, right?”
“Yes, that’s true. There are quite a few
different fungi native to Louisiana.”
Kate answered instinctively, like her brain was
on autopilot; she was more focused on examining
the sample in the box than the conversation.
“Thing is, no one knows what kind this is,
or if it’s dangerous. I heard a rumor the
locals used to call it ‘Frog Rot’, but
apparently that was an older name for it,” the
technician added, garnering little more than
a mumble of agreement from the doctor of botany.
Kate placed the clear, Perspex container near the
window, letting the natural light of the outdoors
give her a better look at what was inside.
It was a portion of a dead tree, its bark soggy
and darkened from the swamp water. Growing out
of its side was a cluster of the mysterious fungus
in question, looking more like pustules or a cyst,
a tumor growing out of the dead wood, as if it
had drained the bigger plant of all its life.
Kate’s next few hours were spent taking samples of
the fungus, keeping her hands and face covered as
she scraped away part of it to examine under her
microscope. There was little abnormal about it
on a cellular level, nothing in testing to suggest
that the sample was toxic or directly harmful. All
Kate could decipher about the plant was that it
was related to a certain genus of fungi known as
Trichophyton – which includes the same parasitic
varieties of fungus that can cause athlete's foot,
ringworm, and similar infections in humans.
Still unable to fully identify the species,
Kate decided to take a closer
look at how it was growing.
Putting the container behind a safety screen,
she opened it up and began to pull apart the
sodden tree bark with her gloved hands. There was
definitely some kind of mass underneath the bark,
what Kate initially assumed to be the wood of
the tree that the fungus had taken root to…
nothing could have prepared her for how wrong she
was. As the bark split apart and crumbled away,
it revealed what was underneath
it: a cottontail swamp rabbit.
The fungi took on even more of a tumor-like
appearance when Doctor Barker saw that it
was actually growing out of the rabbit’s
back, having actually taken root within
the poor creature’s body. As much as the sight
of it was profoundly upsetting – even a little
sickening – the scientist in Kate knew that this
was all just part of nature taking its course.
Once she got over the initial shock, it was even
a little fascinating. Her botanical expertise was
second to none, and through that knowledge, she
knew that most fungi grew in damp conditions.
But she had never seen any genus grow from
the biological matter of another organism,
dead nor alive. Could this mystery species
grow in any biomass? Even in a human being?
Worried about that possibility, Kate went to store
the SCP-306 sample until further testing could be
conducted. As she placed it back in the container,
her hand nudged one of the fungi’s bulbs,
causing it to expel a wisp of tiny spores.
Not that she could see them of course,
they were microscopically small.
But as they drifted through the air,
the spores were drawn to Kate, up and up towards
where she was steadily breathing. The minute the
spores slipped undetected into her airway, Doctor
Barker immediately began coughing, feeling a
disgusting, earthy tang at the back of her throat.
She couldn’t stop spluttering, instinctively
raising her hand to cover her mouth. Her rubber
gloves were still covering her fingers, coated
in even more invisible residue from the fungus,
and now Kate was unknowingly breathing in more.
Excusing herself from work for the rest of
the day, Doctor Kate Barker went home feeling
sicker and sicker as every minute passed. Her
fever was climbing rapidly, limbs shuddering
and still, she couldn’t stop coughing and
spluttering as she tried to expel a foul,
lingering sensation that refused to leave her
throat. But those weren’t even the worst symptoms.
Two days had come and gone since the incident in
the lab, and Kate still hadn’t returned to her
job. How could she? She felt awful, and looked far
worse. Large lesions had started appearing on her
skin, rapidly turning into warts. Just looking
at them made Kate’s stomach turn, and on a few
occasions, poking at them and feeling these alien
lumps on her skin caused her to vomit. Every night
she would go to bed, her body rapidly switching
from swelteringly hot, then becoming cold enough
to cause Kate to shiver uncontrollably.
At first, it looked like the lesions were
clearing, falling away from her skin soon after
they had fully formed into warts. But the fleeting
bit of hope that gave her was quickly wiped away
when new ones started to grow in their place.
This didn’t just feel like flu, or any
other type of sickness for that matter.
It felt painful, on the deepest, tiniest level.
During what little restless sleep she did get,
Kate kept having nightmares about doctors
looking at her cells under a microscope,
watching them changing into… something else.
It had been over two weeks since she had first
been exposed to the SCP-306 spores, and still,
she hadn’t been well enough to go back to work.
Each time Kate had called the human resources
department to inform them she still wasn’t any
better, they always came out with the same advice;
drink plenty of fluids, try to eat, and keep your
strength up. Doctor Barker hadn’t stopped eating
or drinking, albeit at a very slightly reduced
rate. Her appetite had been sapped along
with most of her energy, although she had
noticed that she’d dropped a significant amount
of weight in an alarmingly short amount of time.
Three weeks later, Kate flicked on the
bathroom light and barely recognized herself.
Not only was she no longer at a healthy weight,
but her skin… something was very wrong with her
skin. She had developed an abnormal pigmentation,
a yellowish, greenish hue almost like she had
somehow developed jaundice. But to the touch, it
felt strange, almost a rubbery texture. In fact,
if she hadn’t felt so sick, Kate would have
noticed that her skin wasn’t absorbing water the
way it used to either, displaying the same type
of permeability as the skin of most amphibians.
Two months had gone past and nobody at the
research company had heard a word from Kate.
She wasn’t answering her phone, a few of them
were asked to go to her apartment to check on her,
but she never came to the door either. None
of them had any idea what had happened, they
certainly didn’t know the changes that her body
had undergone… and none of them painlessly either.
The constant pain Kate had been feeling had
gradually built and built, until it felt like
parts of her body were twisting and contorting
against her will and in unnatural ways. With
the grinding feeling of her bones pulling each
other as they shrank, her limbs were wracked
with unbearable agony. At the same time, her
stomach had shrunk to the point where she wasn’t
even able to eat anymore. The same reduction
was occurring to the rest of her organs too,
heart, liver, lungs, brain, everything was getting
smaller, shrinking organs imprisoned within
a skeleton that was also decreasing in size.
Then, one morning, the pain had seemingly stopped.
After a night spent screaming in sheer
agony, tears streaming down her face,
Kate woke up on the floor of her apartment
under a pile of her clothes. But as she awoke,
she instantly noticed something. Everything looked
bigger, the whole room towered above her like she
had been reduced down to the size of something
much smaller than a human. She tried opening
her mouth to say something, anything, but her lips
couldn’t form words anymore. Her arms felt strange
too, like their reach was somehow much shorter,
the same with her legs that were now tucked
under her body. Her tiny, rubbery-skinned
body… SCP-306 had turned her into a frog.
It took Kate almost an entire day to
figure out how to properly move around,
first needing a long time to emotionally process
what had happened to her. If she had still been
able to, she would have been sick and cried
endlessly, wailing on the floor. Instead, when
she tried to make any noise, a tiny croak was all
that emanated from the back of her hoarse throat.
But before she could find a way to leave
her apartment, someone else found their way
in. From way down on the floor, the men in
their white hazard suits looked colossal,
impossibly tall. Kate tried her best to dodge
between the thick soles of their heavy boots
as they came crashing down towards her from
above, each one having enough force behind
it to crush her in an instant. She leaped out of
the way of one descending boot, only to be caught
mid-air in a glass container. As the lid screwed
tightly shut, sealing her inside, Kate was lifted
up and saw a patch on the hazmat uniforms
of the men that had come to take her away:
a black circle, with three arrows pointing in
towards its center, and an outline surrounding it.
The Foundation put her in a glass tank with eleven
other frogs, each of them looking almost identical
to Kate, all climbing over each other, fighting
for their own space in the tiny enclosure. From
the moment she arrived, Kate could see the same
thing in their gaze as they could see in hers;
sadness, unmistakable even in those dark, beady
little eyes. These were people, or at least
they had been human beings at some point. But now
anything on the outside that had made them unique,
their individuality, had been taken away, and
their minds had all been locked inside the same
frog-shaped body as Kate now found herself in.
Over the next few months, the Foundation had
their scientists running a series of tests on
the frogs, who were now all categorized under
the collective designation of SCP-306-1. Even
though she was unable to speak, Kate recognized
their methodical scientific process, how they
would test one or two of the frogs at a time,
note the results, then change a variable and
repeat the test to see if there were any changes.
It was the same process she used to go through
every time a new sample arrived at her lab.
Watching the researchers reminded her of her old
job, the life she’d worked so hard for, and was
cruelly reminded that it was all gone now. Nobody
would ever know where she went. She’d never get to
be out among nature the way she had always loved.
Kate had long since figured out the root cause of
her transformation; a while after she had started
to feel sick, she’d wondered if that strange
fungus had anything to do with it. Seeing all the
Foundation scientists and guards in their hazmat
gear, only handling the other frogs with thick
rubber gloves, seemed to prove her theory right,
and suggested that she and her fellow amphibians
were still infectious. Still, she currently had
no way of communicating with the Foundation
personnel about what had caused her to change,
although they seemed as if they already knew.
Most of the tests involved the researchers
putting Kate and the other frogs into mazes, or
making them solve puzzles, or memorizing commands.
Naturally, having once been human, they all picked
it up quicker than the researchers expected. From
their perspective, these frogs were displaying
an extremely advanced form of intelligence.
Gradually, the testing progressed and the
Foundation’s researchers began attempting to
teach the frog specimens to read and write,
all skills that they already possessed,
even if some of them needed some time to learn
how to hold a pen in their new sticky fingers.
Kate herself was made to complete an IQ test,
scoring 127 points. Now that she had a way to
communicate with these scientists through writing
notes, she and the other SCP-306-1s were asked
their names. That was the moment the
Foundation realized what they were.
These weren’t just frogs, but human beings
who were now trapped in the bodies of frogs.
Perhaps inspired by this human-to-frog
transformation, or possibly as some cruel joke,
one of the Foundation’s researchers – who went by
the name Thomson – brought in a children’s book
and presented it to the collection of SCP-306-1
specimens. At first, Kate enjoyed the simplicity
of the stories, and it seemed her fellow frogs did
as well. But gradually they all grew depressed.
Maybe one of the stories featured a prince
being turned from a frog back into human form,
while the twelve remaining specimens had yet to be
presented with a magical cure for their condition.
Or perhaps seeing something as simple as a
children’s book reminded some of the frogs
of all they were still to do in their
old lives – like starting families – and
now they wouldn’t get the chance.
Kate and some of the other frogs
began writing notes to Thomson and another
of the researchers who had been feeding them,
Fillis. They did their best to be
reasonable with the Foundation,
but also communicate how desperately
they wanted to be set free.
“You have no right to keep us here.” Kate wrote,
under the towering stare of Fillis and Thomson,
feeling for the first time in a long while
that she was actively doing something to
make a difference in nature. “We need to
be out in the world, we need to be free!”
If she had more space on the paper, she would’ve
tried to note down suggestions of places the frogs
could be introduced where they wouldn’t pose any
risk of disrupting the local ecosystem. The swamps
of Louisiana where the SCP-306 fungus had been
found were one such idea that came to mind. But,
much to Doctor Kate Barker’s disappointment, she
and her fellow frogs would only cause the fungi’s
infectious properties to spread, meaning their
pleas with the Foundation fell on deaf ears.
There was no other choice, nothing else
they could do: they needed to break out.
As night fell, Kate organized the frogs,
gradually writing out instructions for how
they were going to escape, communicating with
them the same way she had with the researchers.
Only this time, the others listened. Even if they
couldn’t be human again, they didn’t want to live
the rest of their short lifespans being locked up
and tested forever. Kate marked down the time that
Thomson and Fillis usually fed the frogs, and
drew up a detailed strategy. If she could hide
for long enough under the others, it might make
it seem like one of the specimens was missing…
The next day, Researcher Thomson and Researcher
Fillis arrived to feed the SCP-306-1 specimens,
accompanied by security guards as always.
While her colleague went to collect the
feed for her to administer, Fillis did a count
of the frogs. Eleven. She counted again, only
to get the same result. There was one missing.
As she leaned closer to the tank, Kate trusted
her fellow amphibians above to follow the plan.
In a flash, the mass of frogs had leaped from
their confinement and pinned Fillis to the
ground as one. The room erupted into chaos,
people-turned-frogs leaping in all directions as
they scattered and made a mad dash for freedom.
A gunshot rang out from one of the security
guards trying to subdue the creatures,
only for the stray shot to catch Researcher
Thomson in the neck, killing him.
Leading the charge on her tiny, rubbery legs,
Kate jumped closer and closer to the exit. It was
so close. If she could just get far enough away,
she might finally be free to get back to nature.
Now go and check out “SCP-323 THE WENDIGO SKULL”
to hear another terrifying tale of an anomaly
that could cause someone to undergo a horrific
transformation process. Or if you’re in the
mood for more particularly peculiar plant
life, why not try “SCP-2800 CACTUSMAN”!